اكثر من دراسه تؤيد ظهور اول انسان في
القاره السمراء قبل انتقاله الى اسيا
واوروبا موقع
تحديثا لدراسه عن معهد البيانات الضخمه
التابعه لجامعه اكسفورد كشفت عما يعتقد
انه المكان الذي يتحدى منه اسلاف كل البشر
والنتيجه
المقاله التي نشرها الموقع تتحدث عن خريطه
كامله العلاقات الجنيه بين البشر حيث تمكن
العلماء من انشاء اكبر شجره عائله بشريه
على الاطلاق النتائج المحدثه ترجح باختصار
ان الجميع منهم على قيد الحياه اليوم ترجع
اصولهم الى بلد عربي هذا البلد هو السودان
عندما يتحدث دراسه ان اصول البشر جميعها
من السودان جينيا من الناحيه العلميه الذي
يقصد بذلك الحقيقه ان هذه المعلومات جدا
قديمه لكن الفرق الان بعد اكتشاف الانجي
اس اللي هو الجيل الثالث من السيكونس
للدين ايضا وجود ذاتك كبيره واستطاعوا بعض
العلماء انهم يسوون تحليل لهذه النتائج
اضافوا عليها مثل البيبر منشور الان في
الاكثر من 300
سيكونسينج استطاعوا يحددون ان اصل البشر
بشكل عام هو حقيقه في عبارات سابقه ذكره
اثيوبيا عموما اثيوبيا او السودان هي بنفس
المنطقه
اه هم من وجدوا اول هيكل عظمي بشري متكامل
في اثيوبيا هلا مؤخر الاثار بس من ناحيه
جينيه انا اتكلم من الناحيه دينيه لما
سووا انا لسا جميع السكونس المستوى العالم
في اكثر من 300 سيكونس وبمم بسوفت وير
معين يسوي انا لسه يحدد لك التشابه اللي
يسمونه
فهذا التشابه ادى تاكيد المعلومات انها
لكن المره هذه ما قالوا تيوب قالوا
السودان وهي قريبه من بعض لكن هو معروف
علميا ان اصلا البشر من هذا طبعا انا
اتكلم عن ادم الثنائي اللي هو اكثر من
ثلاثه مليون سنه وما تتكلم عن النبي ادم
اللي هو 7 او 10,000 سنه وبالتالي بدايه
البشر كشر همم في منطقه السودان او منطقه
طيب
وكمان احنا بدنا نعرف بالنسبه لتحديد
السلاله هل هو يرتبط اكثر باصل الام ولا
الاب يعني ايضا
عن طريق الام واللي هو استخدام دي ان اي
لان نيويورك فقط من الام او استخدام
الوايكروميزونز لهنود انه نلعب فقط ايضا
فيد كلاس الدي ان المخلوط ممكن 5 من الام
من الاب يسوون دراسات معينه بحيث انهم
يحددون مايكروستالايت او همم ريبيتيشن
بحيث يعطيك
في المنطقه الفلانيه الان في في ماركه
معين خاص بالروس يعني اي انسان تلقى فيه
ماركه هذا فيكون هذا تابع العرق الروسي
وهكذا طبعا في ابحاث كثيره همم لتاكيد بعض
المعلومات طيب ما فائده هكذا دراسات كان
دراسه جامعه اكسفورد لكلاكم كباحثين لرسم
خريطه الجنيه في العالم ومن الناحيه
الطبيه يعني طبعا اله تستخدم
للجنائيه بالجرائم على ذلك ايضا طبيا مهم
جدا لان الان كثير من الادويه تشتغل على
الريس معين او عرق معين ماتش طالعه اخر
وبالتالي همم يصنعون ادويه يسمونه سمارت
في الجسم الادويه الذكيه بحيث انه يكون
دواء معين خاص بسلاله معينه او خاص بعرق
معينه